foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined by my good friend Jade
warshaw and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five well Jade uh I want to
start off the show with something that
grinds my gears can we do that let's do
it George and that is the iPad tipping
screens and we all agree we need to be
done with those thank God somebody said
something George so Rachel Cruz and I
we've got our smart money Happy Hour
podcast and the most popular episode
we've ever done was called guilt tipping
I listened to All About The Tipping
culture in today's in America especially
this is not a problem in Europe
apparently I hope it doesn't spread over
there no that's not the culture at all
you don't matter of fact it's kind of
like frowned upon it's like if it was
amazing you give them a little bit yeah
sure because you get a living wage but
here in America we decided no make the
people tip when you just ordered your
black coffee and they spin around the
iPad and they start complimenting you
yeah and you subconsciously feel guilty
and go ah the options are 20 40 and one
thousand percent tip I don't know that I
feel guilty George
well you're a better person I think I
feel more irritated well I now hit no
tip exclamatory
they need to put an exclamation point no
tip exclamation let's be clear we're all
about generosity here we're not talking
about not tipping your servers not
tipping your Barbers we are talking
about those little iPads when you are
sitting there and someone just rang you
up and you have a salad you've got no
service for food yet that's right and
they're saying how much do you want to
tip and the preset amounts keep
increasing 20 22 one time there was one
that was 33 I saw this with my own Brown
eyeballs
now here's the thing and and you said it
George this is this is very clear we
have to be crystal clear for the people
restaurant service places where you're
not earning your your hourly wage your
hourly wage is tips we support you
matter of fact tip those people 25 tip
them as much as you can and if you can't
do that then please don't go don't go
out don't go out to eat but I'm talking
about I bought a salad and I haven't
even gotten to see yet did you make it
with no bacon like I asked I'll take the
bacon Jade please don't ever waste it
yeah you know I'll get a little side you
can have the little side thing of bacon
George well there's an article here and
this is spreading now like wildfire the
Hill Covered this here's their headline
why are the default tipping screens set
so high and of course they start the
article with a very clever line have we
reached a tipping Tipping Point very
clever that sounds like something you
might say we should have stolen that
that's good I like this part it says
it's hard to know for sure whether more
establishments are accepting or
soliciting tips then say a decade ago
it's not hard to tell
it's not hard we are everywhere you go
there's that little iPad it doesn't
matter if it's coffee
salad
doesn't matter where you go it's not
hard it's perfect service type places
yeah especially that are guilty of this
and uh here's a quote people think it's
manipulative they resent it and their
perceptions of service go down and there
is guilt involved there's one ice cream
place locally I won't mention the name
because I'm a big fan of their ice cream
I know what you're talking about they
are the service isn't great but all of a
sudden when they ring you up they get
real chatty and real nice okay I don't
like that that's really complimenting me
as they're turning around the hey how's
your day going oh that's that's good to
hear I love that shirt love the glass
love those glasses huh you don't believe
that they love your shirt and glasses no
I believe they want to get in my mind
subconsciously while I'm trying to
choose a tip
nefarious gross man you know here's
where I'm at with this George and and
you this is my personal take and here's
why I get frustrated slash irritated we
already have inflation right which is
already built into the cost of our food
not just groceries people when you go to
the restaurants it's there and we know
that that rate's somewhere around 11.4
percent then you've got the tip
20 and then for you people out there who
are using credit cards
I hope you're not the average credit
card interest rate 19.20 George do you
see what I'm getting at here I just
threw up in my mouth a little do you see
where I'm getting at we're we're I'm not
not me because your girl's not using
credit cards we're not doing that but
the people out there who are engaging in
that way of life they're paying a
premium of over 50 percent uh
for that's why the tip screen I I gotta
just say no just say no if you want to
hear more on this topic go check out
that smart money Happy Hour episode
called Guild tipping how to deal with an
absurd tipping culture you can just
search smart money happy hour wherever
you listen to podcasts and uh if you're
calling in today we'd love to hear your
thoughts on tipping culture and uh if
you're if you're an iPad Tipper and if
you are why did you choose to do that
because you're just perpetuating the
problem at that point yeah well you can
budget for it
that's true there's that and I'm not
saying I never do it yeah I'm saying in
general if there was no service provided
yeah it's a no tip I'd rather save it
I'd rather save it for the the Food
Service workers amen all right it's your
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five Tara joins us in
Albuquerque Tara welcome to the Ramsay
show
absolutely how can we help today
okay so I have to refinance my house
um I'm going to take 10 000 from my
refinance to pay off my car because I
can't afford refinancing and a car
payment
um but I was wondering if I should take
out the additional forty thousand
dollars for a down payment on a new
house so I can make my current home a
rental property as another source of
income well okay a lot going on here so
what what is causing you to refinance in
the first place
uh I'm going through a divorce oh I'm so
sorry to hear that
it's okay thank you I appreciate it is
this in the final stages is it finalized
yet
the divorce yeah yeah so this is the
fine print of the divorce agreement to
refinance to get his name off of the
house okay and you're looking at doing a
cash out refi in order to pull some
money out you want to pay off debt you
want the down payment but you want to
keep this property that's the confusing
part I agree yes I want to keep the
property because
um I I want to make it
um in uh alzheim like investment right
but turn it into a rental home and then
I mean God willing able to go further
with that I have a question so
with the divorce you are able to like
once you do the once you give him his
cut you can sell the house right it
doesn't say that you have to keep it or
anything like that right
um right you know um so he we because we
had um two homes so he got one home I
bought this home this home um just
happens to be under both of our names
and the other home was just under his
name but you're not wanting to live you
didn't get any
um I I'm not
I I do want to live there but I would
like to upgrade into a bigger home
um at some point uh what baby stuff are
you on
um so I guess I'm back to baby step
number one
um I mean I don't have the only the only
um
um get I have is my car and my mortgage
okay so in the baby steps Tara you would
we would tell you hey don't jump into
Home Ownership until you're out of debt
with that emergency fund so if I'm in
your shoes I'm selling this house I'm
getting out of debt I'm renting for a
while and then I can use that down
payment later on down the road to get a
primary residence and the investment
property while it's a great goal that is
a longer term goal you don't want to
have two mortgages at once after going
through what you've been through so I'm
taking my time with this and slowing
down that's good George this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour this is the Ramsey Show open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five you jump in we'll talk about
your life your money what else yeah what
concerns you how to get out of debt how
to build wealth for the future we are
here for you Renee joins us up next in
Cleveland Renee welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you so much for taking my call
um recently got married and we got
ourselves into a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars of debt yes just from
the wedding just from the wedding oh my
God
holy cow and I wasn't even invited the
party that's the party of the century
does that ring look like a disco ball
yeah exactly it's pretty much that yes
oh my goodness okay yes well we're here
so so I want to
um we you know other than a old
um College you know loan debt of about
40 Grand we don't have any other
Consumer Debt we own
um free properties together uh one fully
paid off probably worth about 600 to 700
uh okay
um the other two have mortgages on it
and
um he my husband has about
395 in stocks and bonds oh okay so
there's good news here which is you guys
have a pile of money to clean this up
the question is is he willing to cash
out those stocks and bonds to put you
guys in a place financially that will
cause you to succeed in this marriage
all right okay
hey you know we've all done stupid stuff
with many many zeros attached so we were
poking fun at you earlier but we
definitely know the weight of what
you're facing right now and we're
definitely here to walk with you are
those are those tears because of the
arguments you guys have had around this
yes what it what is the latest
conversations been like when you bring
this up and say hey we're in a big pile
of debt I want to get out of this
well the the other thing is is that the
day after we returned from our uh
wedding weekend she lost his job
[Music]
and he was making over 200k a year okay
okay Renee and how long ago was this
okay are you working at all Renee
yeah
that's a great income
okay what's he doing right now is he
currently looking for work yes okay what
was he doing
yes he was he was in the automobile
industry okay
I have a question uh I have a question
about these properties so you mentioned
three properties one paid off two with
mortgages the one that's paid off is
that your primary residence or is that
it is not it is not it's just a vacation
home okay so that's the vacation home so
that that means the other two with
mortgages one of those is your primary
residence correct okay can you tell me
the numbers on that like what the
mortgage is worth and what you owe
sure so
um let me actually pull that out because
I I I've since had you know we've had
some serious conversations yeah what I'm
getting at is is getting rid of at least
one of these mortgages uh not the
primary residence one and clearing up
some money there and George mentioned
the stocks and bonds if they're not if
they're non-retirement related
definitely wanting to liquidate those
so that's what we're that's what we're
getting at so yeah so the one uh that we
currently live in
um probably has about
235k on it worth about maybe 350.
um the other one with a mortgage is
actually in another state and it has a
much higher
um you know it probably has about 200
inequity in equity
um but the mortgage is about 550. yeah I
if I and this is what I would do if I
were in your shoes if I woke up in your
shoes today I would get rid of that
third property that's got the 200k and
equity
and I would take that money and I would
use it to start paying off the sweat I'd
for sure knock out the student loan
because that's it's just the student
loan and the wedding debt correct that's
your only debt correct I would knock out
that student loan I'd keep a thousand
aside for any savings in case you don't
have baby step one and then whatever's
left I throw it towards the wedding and
then if there's any debt left I'd start
liquidating some of those stocks
I I guess prior because of the location
of the um the third property we've been
probably bringing in about 200k at 200k
my apologies 2K in rental income
um that's per month the one that's out
of state
correct yeah just because it's you know
yeah it's it's in a good location uh the
one that's got the 200k
um
200k is that your net profit
or is that maybe because you still got
to pay the mortgage on that
correct that's my net profit yeah okay I
mean that's not that's good it's good
that you're making a profit on it my
concern is that it's out of state and
then my bigger concern is that you've
got I mean you called us in tears but
because of this debt so at that point
you know you're really weighing the
opportunity cost between the two do you
want to get out of debt how quickly can
we get out of debt uh the other thing
that I'm hearing in this call is and
George correct me if I'm wrong but it
kind of feels like we can give you
um our take on this and we can say hey
this is what we think you need to do but
your husband being on on page with this
is is the other part do you think that
if if he comes home tonight or if you
guys have this conversation and say Hey
I was talking with some experts here is
the plan that they have advised us to
follow what do you think his response is
going to be
well he'll be happy because it's my
property
[Music]
well he's like well that's your business
don't try to sell one of mine but that
worries me because you're married now
it's we it's our properties and so I
want him thinking that way and if he's
not we have a deeper issue here but as
far as liquidating the stocks and bonds
there is going to be tax implications on
the gain so you want to work with the
tax Pro on that to make sure that you're
going to be able to cover this and
understand what's going on there but as
far as this property goes it I don't
want to be a long distance landlord I
mean this is a lot of work for 20K I
agree and so this this cleans up all of
your Consumer Debt and gives you a pile
of money at the end of that and which is
your fully funded emergency fund so this
one property puts you in a completely
different place financially if you sell
it absolutely and I'm I wanted to ask
just because you know I'm always
thinking about the baby steps do you
have any other money saved like just
laying around saved up for a rainy day
three to six months anything like that
yes okay about 45k so here think about
it like this Renee if you if you follow
the advice that we've given you you're
still gonna be
millionaires you've got this vacation
home that's worth 700 you've got your
primary real estate that's worth 350
just right there alone your net worth
millionaires all right and then you know
I don't think that I don't know how much
is in the stocks and bonds that you have
you may not have to liquidate all of
that but do you see what I'm saying
about
390. oh come on now so this is great if
I'm in your shoes I'm selling that third
property and cashing out the stocks and
bonds making sure I can pay the taxes on
that and that's going to put you guys in
a completely different place because you
can pay off the other mortgage now you
have zero payments in the world and
everything is Cash flowing with a
hundred percent profit going to you yeah
with very little stress in your life as
newlyweds I know that's right suddenly
you're you're wiping those tears and
you're rejoicing because you're suddenly
ahead of 90 of the people out here do
you see that yes yes now we need him to
see it yeah
send him this call
hopefully he did but I do like the
solution I'll be honest I I've been
afraid to let go of that because it
because it is mine it's the only
property that I actually own and it's
been a cash cow for me for a long time
but you're right when you put it in
perspective and say only 20 grand a year
like forget it you make over triple that
and you can always get another property
that's the thing the way we're setting
you up you'll be able to if you want to
purchase more real estate you'll be able
to do it you'll be able to cash flow it
and it's going to be a blessing not a
burden and he's gonna be back to work in
no time making great money but right now
this is a great moment for you guys to
reset Clean Slate this is we now how are
we going to set ourselves up financially
for a successful marriage for successful
wealth building for the future and this
is a way to do it and it's a good
problem to have when you have all this
money sitting around in different
Pockets put it to good use and make
yourself free
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours
each week since we made the switch to
netsuite netsuite is a game changer so
head on over to netsuite.com Ramsey to
get a product tour today that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
open phones at
888-825-5225 this is the Ramsey show our
question of the day is coming up here
and it is from Brittany in Kentucky what
does Brittany have to say Jade
Brittany in Kentucky says this I'm
currently on baby step two but I'm
having a hard time reconciling the debt
snowball on credit cards that can be
paid off over time without interest
accruing as long as I pay them off
before the end of the interest-free
promo but I was hoping to use the
avalanche on my loans not my credit
cards in my mind I'd rather pay extra
money on the interest heavy loans and
diligently pay off my credit cards thus
taking advantage of the interest-free
promos side note I've cut up all my
credit cards and I'm sticking to my zero
budget diligently could you help me
understand the best course of action
it sounds like Britney wants to do her
own course of action personally yeah
she's she's working her own plan so what
she's talking about here is the
Avalanche method of paying off debt
which says pay the highest interest
debts first and make your way down
regardless of the balance the debt
snowball method which is the one that
we've taught here for 30 years now is
pay off the smallest balance first
regardless of the interest rate that's
right you know makes you scratch your
brain when you go well it's zero percent
interest why would I even pay that off
you know from my pers experience and I
believe the experience of the millions
of people who have worked the baby steps
and used you know the debt snowball as
their method we've learned that you know
when it comes to money Dave says it all
the time it's 80 per 80 Behavior 20 head
knowledge right and so there's something
that builds up in our behavior when
we're working the debt snowball for me
it was about getting those quick wins
right George when you put them from
smallest to largest you're able to knock
out those small debts quick and you feel
like oh my gosh I can do this you start
to believe that you can actually pay off
your debt and you know we've said that
personal finance is 80 Behavior 20 head
knowledge and the people who are making
these arguments they're focusing on the
head knowledge but I'm always going if
this isn't a life hack to try to take
advantage of the zero percent you got
yourself in a pile of debt and so if you
were so astute and disciplined to pay
off the highest interest rate first you
wouldn't have gotten into debt in the
first place that's right George so
there's a whole nother mentality here
going like I'm gonna hack the system
that I trapped myself in and so we found
and it's not just a Dave thing it's not
just Dave Ramsey says and yeah millions
of people have done it if that's not
enough for you there are new studies
from Harvard Business review from Texas
A M saying the debt snowball method
works better that's right if Harvard
says it I'm biting and uh here's the
direct quote snowballing your debts is
from Chicago Tribune paying the smallest
to largest regardless of finance charges
might not make sense mathematically but
it just might work better according to
their new academic study and so this
isn't anecdotal because we meet these
people I I don't I haven't met someone
who's like I am an avalanche debt-free
screamer I just don't meet them I don't
meet them either and I think it's
because it's harder to gain traction and
so you stay in the process longer and
yes on paper you would pay less interest
if you could do The Avalanche message
with discipline but the truth is we are
human beings yeah and we need that
progress we are wired to feel that
problem we need to feel the wind and
it's it's tough because when we think
about money our mind goes directly to
the numbers it goes to the math but in a
lot of cases money is not mostly about
the math it's mostly about your mindset
and you feeling like you're winning and
you feeling like you can succeed and
definitely the debt snowball sets you up
for that yeah staring at a giant pile of
debt that has the high interest rate and
going all right I got to tackle this one
first it's like me starting running by
going all right I'm gonna run a marathon
and then work my way backwards to the 5K
oh gosh that doesn't make sense so why
do we do that with our money
end quote that's it well hey thank you
for the question Brittany uh I encourage
you to use the debt snowball method and
come here and do your debt free scream
and share your story because it works
every time you work it it does that's
all I got to say about that all right
let's go to Stacy in Sacramento she is
waiting there Stacy welcome to the show
thank you thank you for taking my
question absolutely how's it going
well good good I'm sort of at a
crossroad and just hopefully needs some
guidance and support here um I'm married
women California as you mentioned
Sacramento area we have no kids we're in
our early and mid-40s we make about 230
000 uh combined gross income you don't
have any debt except for our homes when
I say homes because we just recently
purchased a home in this worst time of
the year
um at any rate I used about 235 thousand
dollars
oh did I mention I'm sorry I'm also at
baby steps four of seven great um I used
about 235 000 in my personal savings
um that I had put down on the new house
that I will get back once we sell our
old house that is currently on the
market
okay um and so once I get you know once
we net out the 235 000 back to me from
the old house we should have about a 250
000 profit left over okay so um you know
with having two mortgages and two you
know utilities we've been stretching
ourselves pretty soon this past couple
months I bet so it has been tough and
especially in California when everything
feels like it's tripled I'm sure it
hasn't everywhere else but is it looking
good for the that home sale I mean how
long has it been on the market
a month and a half okay it's been on the
mark for a month and a half so it's
looking we don't have an offer yet so
um but it's killing us because we've got
higher interest rate on this new home
um it's 30-year fixed loan
um 30-year fixed home loan and um we
just really want to pay off the new home
loan ASAP so I guess where I'm sort of
questioning is how we once we do sell
the old home and we get 250 000 profit
I'm curious to know if you recommend
whether or not we apply that to the
current loan the current new home loan
and then roll the dice with Fannie Mae
to recast the loan or should we just
wait to apply to 250 000
profit to a refinance maybe an 18 to 24
months the interest rate gets lowered
and six and a half percent which is what
we got well if you were going to
refinance I would want you to refinance
to a 15-year right would that payment be
too much for you guys it would be more
than 25 of your take-home pay
it'd probably be closer to 30 or 40
maybe but what if you use a 250 to pay
down the mortgage and then later down
the line you could refinance to the 15
year if you wanted to and it made sense
financially I like that idea George
that's my bad idea yeah that might be a
possibility yeah pay the 30 like a 15
and yeah like a 10. pay like a seven I
mean you could how quickly could you do
this you're kind of re re-engineering
the whole idea because ideally they
would have sold the old house first
gotten their 250 and then purchased the
new house and my guess is that if you
had gotten the money in that order you
would have put a lot more of that money
to this new house so I kind of like
George's idea of taking that money
putting it to the house when you sell it
and then you know when the time is right
to refinance you're and you're just in a
better situation what's your current
mortgage
what's left on the loan
what's on the old house on the new one
the 30-year fixed and the new one is
41.50 a month a month What's the total
loan
504 5 000. okay so if you applied the
250 that would take you down to about
300 left
and then you guys are making 230 how
quickly could you pay off 300 000 making
230 with no debt
that's a good point a few years right
yeah I think when we met it out the
amortization schedule something like
eight and a half years or so
um but yeah I mean I guess if you want
to get inspired Stacy go to our website
ramseysolutions.com and use our early
payoff calculator under the tool section
and start to play around with the
numbers and you once you start to see
that you can't unsee it I know that's
when you're like oh we put 4 000 a month
towards that extra on top of them or
what we could be debt we could be before
we turn 50 completely debt free and baby
steps millionaires with a paid for house
in California do you know how crazy and
weird that would be I like the sound of
that and then guess what we can retire
early instead of having to work until
we're 65 what if we could retire 55 what
would we do where would we go what could
we buy how much could we give that's
where Life starts to get exciting
why do you think Stacy
that makes a lot of sense it's just yeah
absolutely I think you should I think
you need to go for it I think you need
to uh take George's advice here and uh
start dreaming a little get rid of that
you know take that money throw it to the
house man here's the good news Stacy if
you regret it you can always go get
another mortgage the banks are happy to
give you more debt but I have a strong
feeling that when you have no payments
in the world you're going to be on cloud
nine going uh I'm good I'm glad with the
decision we made so we're cheering you
on you guys are in a great spot uh we're
rooting for you to become completely
debt free this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
While most of you are probably glad to
rid of 2022 it was just hard enough to
keep gas in the car food in the fridge
and money may still be tight for so many
of you out there and you're wondering is
this year going to be any different is
it going to be more struggle more
anxiety well good news for you you do
not have to live through another year of
stress and worry and that's why we want
you to tune in to our free live stream
called Building Wealth in 2023 happening
this week this Thursday night because we
want to show you that you can still make
progress on your goals you can build
wealth you can have peace with money
even in this crazy economy during this
event you'll hear from myself Rachel
Cruz Dave Ramsey John deloney Ken
Coleman and we're going to talk about
how to set goals how to create margins
so that you can build wealth this year
we're gonna have some fun as well some
fun surprises planned and you are going
to leave fired up for 2023 and this is a
great event to share with your friends
because let me remind you it is free and
you can live stream it from anywhere in
the world so guys even if the economy
feels out of control this year you don't
have to feel out of control register for
the free live stream at
ramsaysolutions.com
wealth that's ramseysolutions.com
wealth open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five jet joins us
in Lubbock Texas jet welcome to the show
hey guys how are you man big big fan so
um very honored to be on the show no we
appreciate that we are honored to have
you how can we help today
yeah so I've I've been uh hard time
doing or I've done all the steps pretty
much except for number six uh recently
new married
um so I've been married for about five
months I'm 24 she's 21. she's got
another semester of college left we're
fully paying that with cash awesome and
we're looking to move we're feeling very
led to kind of get out of Lubbock we've
been there our whole lives and the
Lord's pushing us to move and my
question for y'all and this time is it
better to when you do move if we're
starting a family in a new city would
you start looking for a house and really
build a family in a house and put all
your money into that or is it time to
rent and stay there for a year or two
and then try to buy a house yeah you
know you're newly married you're going
to a new city if it's me I'm going to
rent for a little while I'm gonna rent
I'm gonna get to know the area you know
find out if this is really you know do
we like this area you might get there
and after six months be like oh man that
other side of town that's really the
place to be you know and I I definitely
think that that's the wiser choice
because once you once you buy you know
you're locked in and it's expensive to
move it's expensive to sell so renting
in in this case I think George would be
that's the choice I'd make absolutely
and it turns out babies they don't need
a lot of space and they don't know the
difference between a rental and a home
and so that's the good news while
they're young and so I love that you're
thinking that far ahead going hey we
want to start a family I want you to be
a homeowner but I'm I'm with Jade on
this I'm gonna rent somewhere sign a six
month lease a 12-month lease you can
always renew and the key here is what
are we doing to get ourselves in a
position to get a home the right way
where it is it's not a it's not a
stressor it's a blesser that's right and
and George is right jack you guys have
been very smart you're in baby step six
I mean this is excellent you should have
plenty of money to start saving up for a
great down payment you've got time
you're not in a rush and if that's the
one thing that you you leave coming off
of this call is hey there's no rush the
next goal is how much of a down payment
can we save and here's what that does by
the way when you take your time and you
have the patience and you build up this
big down payment and you can put 20 or
more down and your mortgage is now less
than a quarter of your take-home pay yes
here's what that does when your wife
wants to stay home one day with the baby
it's not even a conversation you just go
okay cool we just got adjust the budget
nothing much is going to change we can
cover it but when you are up to your
eyeballs with a mortgage for a house you
barely can afford on that 30-year and
one person says I want to stay home you
guys go
you can't breathe at that point and so
just put yourself in a position where
you have that kind of op those kinds of
options that is my goal for you guys as
a newlywed couple
that makes sense I like that one that's
kind of where we are you know we've got
I've got great savings she has great
savings and you know we're able to put a
very Hefty down payment on but we just
are like I think we should rent and see
the area and so tell her definitely
clarifying and affirming my thoughts and
our thoughts I love it well number one
jet you're gonna have to ignore a lot of
the voices that are going to be coming
your way from friends and family going
jet what are you doing man you should be
a homeowner it's such a sin to rent
you're throwing away money out the
window those people can shove it because
they don't get to say when it comes to
your money in your life they're not
experiencing the stress that you feel uh
and especially as a newlywed couple you
guys are figuring out life that's right
at home ownership on top of that as a
whole nother layer that is very
stressful I feel like that's been a
theme homeownership what to do with the
mortgage how to buy the mortgage how to
save for the mortgage I feel like that's
been a theme this this hour what an
American dream of home ownership turns
out it's a lot more complicated than we
thought it's more stressful it's more
expensive than we thought yeah it's
something that I want for everyone but
it has a time and a place that's right
and I think you know what you said is
true but you can eliminate some of the
stress out of it you can eliminate some
of the fear some of the remorse out of
home buying if you follow the the
principles that we teach when it comes
to buying a home you know that that
15-year fixed mortgage that is
everything and I know people struggle
with that because it's for some people
it means payments higher on the 15 years
well you know what that's because that's
what you can afford but it's a bigger
number you get less house I want the
smaller number well you know what that's
that's what's wrong with our our
spending culture is we try to get as
much as we possibly can and we end up in
debt up to our eyeballs give me all the
small numbers added up and you're still
broke yeah man just just pull back buy
what you can afford the whole goal right
is for us to be debt free absolutely we
want to get to that quickly good stuff
all right Charles is up next in
Asheville North Carolina Charles welcome
to the show
oh thank you such a great honor to talk
to you you as well how can we help today
uh Ben
both the 73 and uh we've got some rental
home we've been married eight years we
both got married after our spouse's
Bible cancer we've been hired eight
years but we've been nursing these uh
rental properties you know how that is
one thing after the other and we just
decided hey we don't want to do this
anymore it's working us to death so we
we got rid of one rental property and
we've got the two two other ones that
are for sale and we've had good a good
looking you know a lot of people looking
at them so we're just trying to figure
out what to do we're going to end those
two houses are going to be pretty much
Awash because we've got capital gains
and you know so forth but uh we're going
to end up with at least a hundred
thousand dollars to invest or to um you
know do something else with you know we
want to do our ties and offering and be
able to help other people and that's
what we're trying to get to and so we're
trying to figure out what's up at this
stage of our life we're both in good
health that uh we just want to be able
to go with you've got no debt all our
credit cards and everyone and then we're
doing plastic surgery on them
are all the properties paid off
the the two rental houses that are for
sale now are not paid I'd have mortgage
against them and so that's what we say
once those two are sold they'll be you
know you'll be completely debt free
yeah do you have any other money in
retirement
uh we don't
um I bought we bought this house in
Waynesville this is our retirement home
960 square feet and it's paid for what's
it worth uh I own a house in Burlington
North Carolina which is my mother's
house she has lifetime rights and once
it's you know once she passes I just
can't live there any more then we'll
sell it and that'll be more additional
income coming in later she's 101 so wow
she's holding on I don't know are both
of you retired and other none of you are
working
yeah we're both retired and tired but we
are retired yet well so all of these
rental properties this is your only
income do you have any Social Security
is there any else anything else coming
in what's your monthly income
uh I'm in Social Security is 5300 okay
and is that is that more than enough for
you guys to live once these properties
are paid off yeah
our monthly expenses run about two
thousand dollars a month okay okay well
if you've got a hundred thousand dollars
and you've got no debt including any of
these properties there are multiple ways
you can invest this uh one outside of
retirement is just in a brokerage
account in an index fund or a mutual
fund and at a you know an average return
let's say you get eight or let's say ten
percent on a hundred thousand dollars
for easy round numbers well that's ten
thousand dollars a year that you can
pull away from that hopefully without
pulling away the principal too much
so that's one option for you Charles and
I would connect with a smartvester pro
because we are down to like we got to
really figure out how to maximize this
money and so I would work with one of
our smart wrestler pros at
ramseysolutions.com to make the most of
that money so that you guys can have a
great retirement with the money you've
got and uh hopefully these properties
can do that for you once they're paid
off in cash flow
thanks so much for the call that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show and the
books my thanks to my co-host Jade
warshaw all the guys in the booth and
you America thanks for tuning in we'll
be back real soon
[Music]
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined by
Jade warshaw this hour and we are taking
your calls America at this number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Hatton kicks us off this
hour in Oklahoma City Hatton welcome to
the Ramsey show how you doing
I'm doing very well how are you all
doing we're doing good how can we help
today
yes
a bit of debt to the tune of about 7 300
but as of right now it looks like I'll
have that loan paid off in mid-February
cool
so
um I guess my question is I mean I've
pretty much been trying to go score
search at it for the last several weeks
and I'm getting married in September so
how congratulations and I thank you how
can I start my marriage off and make
sure that it is going to be successful
financially because I don't want to end
up in a situation like this again and
also wanted to factor in that I will be
graduating from college this coming
April wonderful exciting that's really
exciting how old are you
um 24. 24 what are you graduating uh
from what degree what are we talking
I am graduating with a Bachelor of
Science in Ministry and Bible from
Ambridge University in Montgomery
Alabama should be around graduating
summa [ __ ] laude very cool very cool so
um are you planning on going into
Ministry being a pastor or what I'm
actually working with a church down in
Southwestern Oklahoma now cool I love it
is your bride-to-be does she have any
debt
uh no she will not have any debt coming
in very good is she coming in with any
kind of assets or money savings she'll
she will have a savings account yes that
she'll be bringing over good woman
that's fantastic well you're alluding to
how to set yourself up already which is
get out of debt and have a pile of money
in the bank that is going to cause the
least amount of money fights and money
problems as you guys start this life
together absolutely and having the same
views on debt too you know it sounds
like both of you value a debt-free
lifestyle and so coming into the
marriage on the same page as far as what
your values are surrounding money I
think you know you guys have you've set
yourself up I mean I think you're going
to get rid of this loan for 7 300
lickety-split your wife's got no debt
and I think as long as you continue to
operate your life like that no debt
follow the baby steps you're going to be
calling back here in I don't know 12
years 16 years whatever the time is
you're going to be a baby steps
millionaire absolutely absolutely and
you guys plan on cash flowing this
wedding I assume
yes we we have all of our bigger ticket
items paid for now and we're just gonna
try to cash flow the rest and I'm also
going to be going on for graduate
degrees but by the time I get this loan
paid off I'll be able to cash flow all
the way through with scholarships and
and all this kind of a thing that's
awesome is that what the loan was for it
was for school
um no it was a personal loan because I'd
run up some debt on a credit card and I
had taken it out to get out some under
um
I uh get out of them under a higher
interest rate I see got it I got it down
to about six and a half percent and I
just made about another eleven hundred
and fifty dollars worth of payments on
the loan and it's down to about twenty
one hundred dollars now okay and you cut
up the credit card right
uh yes is it is the account closed
I have not closed it yet but I'm going
to be getting on the phone I just closed
that account shut her down with one
place and I'm gonna be getting ready to
yes good I do that today do that today
Hatton that was one of the best
decisions I made was cutting up that
those cards and I know that I thought
they were a blessing to me because of
the airline miles and the cash back and
the credit score I didn't need it and
you don't either had and you guys are
doing great and I want to gift you
Financial Peace University as a
pre-marital counseling gift it's one of
the best tools to get on the same page
have common goals common language to
talk about money so I want to gift you
one year of that watch online lessons
with your bride to be and that will set
you up for Success my man thanks for the
call all right Abby's up next in Boise
Abby welcome to the show
thank you how are you we're doing good
great how can we help
well I am just
I'm just I am hospice nurse and also a
director for two branches here in Idaho
and I recently started following Dave
Ramsey and so now I am wanting to get
out from under the debt that I have with
that being said I am a salaried employee
and so I have a cap on the income I
bring in obviously and so looking into
it being a nurse there are a lot of
different options and I found an option
that I could get an additional
certificate and kind of pave the way for
making kind of whatever it is that I'm
willing to put in now with that being
said trying to get debt free this is
going to take another probably about
seven to eight thousand dollars in order
to get this licensure and so I was
wondering if that is something I should
do now or if I should wait until I get
out of debt to do that how much are you
making right now
um household income is about 188 000 a
year 180
and that's you and your husband combined
yes ma'am okay okay just double checking
this feels like a both and to me I think
you can continue paying on the debt but
set aside some money to get this
certification how how much would it
increase your income by
well again that's going to depend on how
much I work and I'm a worker so it could
be anywhere from you know an additional
you know 25 to 5 grand a month or this
guy is the limit and it could replace
what I do now other than this is my love
so I want to add to it
um don't really want to step out of it
but I do want to have some options
because salary has just heard for me
because I know I work 60 hours a week
um and you know you've got the cap how
much debt do you guys have
um so we just purchased a home in March
um and so we've got the home debt of
about 550 000 and then I've got about
five thousand dollars in credit cards
and I owe about 18
000 on my Forerunner and that's all the
debt that you have between both you and
your husband
yeah perfect so you got 23 in Consumer
Debt we can clean that up in a few
months right very quick oh for sure and
so once you I here first I'm cleaning
off this 23 000 in Consumer Debt I'm
Gonna Save that emergency fund and get
that certification and cash flow that
and you'll be able to do that all within
the next what six to nine months should
be
well here's the other thing I'm sitting
on about a thirty thousand dollar save
well money market account
um don't bury the lead what are you
doing with the savings account listening
to Dave okay okay what am I what so
let's keep let's let's do it like this
let's let's do the baby steps in order
so you've got let's keep out of that 30
000 that you have in the money market
account let's keep a thousand set aside
for baby step one let's put everything
else on your debt your clean up your 23
000 there and then you should have
plenty six left over yeah plenty left
over to to start you on your three to
six months and then get that built up
and then you know definitely cash flow
this certification it sounds like it's
gonna it's gonna Roi in Spades oh and
you freed up those payments at that
point and so I mean within a few months
you could be completely debt free with a
fully funded emergency fund and cash
flow the certification that's that's the
path I'm going down Abby that is awesome
good for you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show and about this
time of year we get flooded with calls
on the show because everyone is looking
for a fresh start with their money
especially after a tough couple of years
so if that's you you can't wish for
things to change and just expect it to
happen you've got to do some things
differently when it comes to money
you've got to have a plan and we've got
the perfect plan for you in Financial
Peace University this is the course that
will help you rethink how you manage
your money and you will learn step by
step how to pay off debt and how to
build wealth and nearly 10 million
people have taken FPU followed this plan
and changed their lives I'm one of those
people Jade is one of those people this
stuff works don't try to reinvent it
don't try to do your own plan we got the
plan for you and when you intentionally
follow this with Focus intensity this
year will be different you will have
more peace in your finances and your
life so start Financial Peace University
right now at ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU man I hope people take advantage of
this and I hope they sign up for the
class George because it is a true life
changer
it's one of those where like when it
comes to working out you're saying oh
this is gonna be the year I start
working out and then it just doesn't
happen yeah this is one of those where
like you get in the boot camp and you're
around other people and you're like this
is actually I'm having a good time I'm
fired up yeah but I want to show up
again next week you got to show up and I
gotta tell people you know this plan it
works when you work it you can't you
know you can't log in and only do one
class you gotta finish it through you
got to do all the classes see it through
till the end and follow it don't don't
make up your own method now because once
you start making up your own method
that's when you go by the wayside
believe me I tried it and you know after
the nine weeks of watching all the
videos going through the lessons doing a
budget if you hate it and you thought
your life before was so much better you
can always go back to that you can
always go back and that's the thing do
the courses you can do the courses on
your own in your own time if you can get
into a group like a coordinated group I
love that method as well the best
setting matter of fact George I think no
I know that I am going to coordinate an
FPU class all right I'm going to court
I need to see how many people are
interested George because look I'll do
it whether it's ten or ten thousand okay
well you're talking to way more than
that right now it feels like you have an
unfair advantage to get people in this
class look who wouldn't sign up for the
class with Jade well I don't know if
your interest competition is who would
sign up for my class versus your Club oh
that is not a bet I'm willing to George
are you trying to take are you trying to
take take on George no I would never
compete against you James I'm trying to
step to me you should step to me let's
do it you're too competitive for me I
would just let you win the game just
because it would make us both lose we
could do it together George we could we
could coordinate a club no matter who's
coordinating go through this class
Ranger solutions.com change your life
FPU love it all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Byron joins us up next in Colorado
Springs Byron welcome to the show
hey there guys really appreciate you
having me on absolutely
so yeah here's a situation uh kind of
lost a lot of money in the stock market
put my family in debt I've got a wife
and three kids so kind of disappointed
what happened but
um long story short
um you know during the stock market boom
and I believe it was 2018 2020
um with GameStop and AMC uh kind of got
into stock market with that uh made a
lot of money
through the options trading of the stock
market and didn't really know what I was
doing
so I brought 60 000 to about 130 000.
and then lost it all
and so that's kind of where it gets a
little bit fishy too I started trying to
make it back
took out a 25k loan put in the stock
market lost it all
and that's kind of where we're at today
um I've got a car loan for about 40K
we're about 7K in medical debt
uh 5500 in a credit card payments and
we've also got our mortgage to pay for
so
I really dug myself in a hole guys and
really looking for help right now
I'm sorry to hear about this man this
that you you touched about the hottest
over you could touch and I hope you are
done with playing with single stocks and
options trading especially which is one
of the riskiest versions of trading
there is out there
yeah I'm done with that completely now
what's your income
uh 120k per year okay and is that
household is your wife working outside
the home
uh no she is a stay-at-home mother okay
what kind of work do you do
engineering defense Contracting cool is
there any opportunity to to work more to
clean this up
uh yeah I would be willing to look into
that I just I guess I don't really know
what would be feasible
um with time and opportunity costs I
haven't really explored that option and
that 25k was that a personal loan how
did you take that out
okay so if I'm adding this up correctly
are we talking about close to 80k or so
in debt Consumer Debt
I think after we calculated we're around
98k actually I probably might have left
a few things out of there okay okay one
option
is to get rid of the car because that
would clear 40K that would clean up half
your debt tomorrow what does the car
worth
right now we currently own about 40K on
it
um I I believe I checked out CarMax in
their cash now offers about 35 000 I
believe okay do some more homework on
that check with a bunch of different
dealerships check private party value
because if you can get 40K for that and
you get any money in the bank anything
in savings
no there's anything non-retirement
yeah I was going to ask is the stock
money completely gone there's nothing
left
it's completely gone okay
all right so that puts you at this baby
step one which is we got to get a
thousand dollars in the bank as soon as
possible do you have that
uh next paycheck yes we can do that okay
beyond that we're going to start to pay
off all these debts smallest to largest
regardless of interest rates and the car
obviously would help clean this up even
if you took a small loss on it it would
clean this up obviously you need another
card you guys have another vehicle you
could use or could you buy a a cheap
five thousand dollar car
uh yeah we've got family in town and I'm
sure we could definitely use one of
their cars for a bit because right now
it feels overwhelming and I think
getting rid of this car would
emotionally and financially benefit you
and you can always get that car later
and do it with cash and do it the right
way
okay
so that is one thing you could do I'm
just giving you options here are you
currently investing at all in anything
uh we have our retirement account that's
untouched so let's
how much have you been contributing to
that
um so
I guess before I lost everything at the
stock market I was doing the company
match so I was about eight percent but
then when everything kind of went
down
um I stopped contributing and just tried
to start using all the money to pay the
debt so we're not doing that anymore
okay let's keep that paused until we get
rid of all this Consumer Debt and we
have a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months now make it the good
news is you have a great income you make
120k and you've got 98 000 in debt now
if we clean up the car that leaves you
with about 58 and now you're going all
right I make 120k and I got 58 to pay
off how quickly could we do that how
much could you set aside from your
income having paused all the Investments
at probably what 30 40K a year towards
this debt
yeah
um I guess my only concern would be our
mortgage is currently 3 000 a month so
it's a pretty big chunk and what's your
take on pay
7 200.
that is that's a hefty chunk and that's
on a 30-year
yes
yeah you're looking at 42 we need to get
this income up basis yeah sudden
suddenly selling the car is not an
option we need to do that this is a
necessity yeah okay
because right now you're not going to
have a lot of margin to throw at the
debt if half of your income is going
towards the mortgage alone that's right
Byron you're going to have to do
everything you can you're going to have
to work more and I know we talked about
it earlier and it was like oh what's the
opportunity cost at this point it
doesn't matter you need to pick up you
need to be working 80 hours a week if
your wife can pick up work if she can do
something inside of the home it to earn
money you guys have really got to get
that income up here's the good news
you've got a lot of small debts so
you're going to be able to feel those
wins quicker I hate debt but I like when
it's broken up like this because you can
feel the winds and you start doing a
budget man we're going to give to you
one year of every dollar premium to get
on a plan you're going to start selling
stuff you're going to start finding
money in the couch cushions the kids are
going to get involved this is going to
be a family affair to get this debt out
of our Lives once and for all and you'll
never look back man you'll never dip
your toes in those Waters you learned
his lesson all those volatile single
stocks and uh man that's a tough
situation
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Jade
warshaw we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five well Jay last week we were talking
taxes talking about all the tax changes
talking about why refunds are a bad idea
yeah and then some fans sent us this and
it is from H R Block here's their big
headline on their site up to 3 500 could
be yours within minutes of filing apply
for a refund advance loan at the end of
your tax prep and you could get up to 3
500 the same day you file why do I hate
this already zero percent APR No loan
fees no credit score impact
that they're making this about if
they're using like credit and credit
card language and all that kind of
reminds me of is that old like JG
Wentworth like it's my money and I want
it now like it's that Vibe George
there's such a lack of patience in
today's society that were like I know
I'm getting my refund in April which by
the way is just a loan to the government
interest-free okay not a gift and on top
of that they're like I can't wait until
April because I'm so broke and need the
money so desperately and HR Block is
going to be my my shining night I hate
to save the day I hate this for a lot of
reasons George it's really just
perpetuating a a unhealthy mindset about
money it really is and the way it works
if you're wondering if you're approved
the loan funds are loaded onto an H R
Block prepaid Mastercard which
technically is a debit card but it
doesn't act like a debit card in the
ways you might think because in the fine
print which you know I check there's a
link to the fee schedule come on they
don't even put the fee schedule under
the FAQ under the drop down they put it
on a whole another page give us the fine
print oh my good I mean it would take me
hours to read this off
just give us the high level five bucks
for a cash reload fee there's a four
percent check to card fee three bucks
for ATM withdrawals 35 bucks for
over-the-counter withdrawals 150 if you
do an ATM balance inquiry 150 for ATM
declined five bucks for inactivity 35
bucks if you lose your card yeah I'm
getting mad I'm getting mad right now
George because broke people are needing
this and so their answer is to nickel
and then dime them to keep them broke
this was your money
that this refund was already your money
you already loaned it to the government
at zero percent and now they're loaning
it back to you and they're charging you
for it
insane and here's what they say uh you
don't pay until your refund arrives you
can wait to repay your loan until the
IRS delivers your refund and when it's
time to repay it we've got options well
why what does that mean that's why don't
you just wait anyway why don't you just
wait this is pointing to this is America
Jade I don't wait for nothing uh well
you bet you're gonna learn right now
Prime now no no no no no I hate this I I
just two hour delivery 30 minutes or
it's free it's not the America I live in
I will wait to get all of my money and
if you're in in such Dire Straits that
you gotta take out a loan or whatever
this is to get your refund advance and I
hate the way they say it they try to
make it so positive refund advance to
get your money early and then you know
all those list of fees that you're why
can't you just wait why can't you just
get your stuff in line file your taxes
as early as possible which means you get
your refund as early as possible and
just wait to have your money and better
yet like George said adjust your with
holding and take that money and just add
it to your monthly checks so you can
just leave all of this in the dust
behind you amen what about that George H
R Block You've Done rile Jade up okay
done it and now we're dogging H R Block
a bit and there's some there's some fine
people who you know might prepare your
taxes at H R Block they're not all bad
people some of them are really quality
but some of them just had to go through
like a little online course and now
they're preparing your taxes and they
only really do simple tax returns yeah
which you could then go do for free if
boots was doing my taxes I can do my
taxes thank you if boo boo can sign up
for the H R Block course and do my taxes
then Jade can get Ramsay smart tax
Booboo can do it you can too that's the
theme of this segment haha well thank
you for that Jade Good Times all right
let's get to your calls America Andrea
joins us in Kansas up next Andrea
welcome to the show
thank you
what's your question today
my question is um I'm really new to
Ramsay I'm just I'm step one maybe step
one
um but the first thing I want to do is
adjust my deductions on my paycheck
because currently I claim head of
household in zero so they're just taking
out the most that they can and then
every year I get a refund but I'd like
to figure out how I know how much
deductions I need to adjust so that I
break even at the end of the year and I
get my money throughout the year I love
it what a perfect question perfect tax
returns and deductions and withholdings
so you need to work with your employer
and HR to adjust those settings and
there's a great calculator on the IRS
website I don't say that often but if
you go through and fill out all your
information on that calculator they will
tell you exactly what you need to set up
with your deductions and withholdings
that's right they can have you done that
yet Andrea
I have not I talked to my HR department
and they
um they had me log into Paylocity and
she said I could just do it all myself
but and you're not very familiar with
the program you could do it yourself
what they're going to have you do is
pull up that W-4 and make those tweaks
but what George was saying is first do
your due diligence and use that
calculator to find out and estimate what
your withholdings should be and then
you'll be able to know what it needs to
look like on that W-4
okay are you working with a tax Pro
already or have you been doing your
taxes yourself no I been doing it myself
so I mean I don't have extremely
complicated taxes but I just want to try
and get out of debt and make the most of
my money so I love it because this is
the first one well if this is a pain
point for you you can always reach out
to a pro that we have vetted in your
area at ramseysolutions.com and click on
Ramsay recommends we've got tax Pros
called endorsed local providers in the
Wichita area to help you navigate these
Waters and make the most of your money
okay
thanks so much for the call appreciate
it Cooper is up next in Lubbock Texas
Cooper Welcome to the show
uh yes sir thank you guys for having me
absolutely what's going on
yes sir so I'm actually 19 I'll be 20
here in the next couple of months I just
secured a job as a firefighter here in
Texas and uh I've been with the same
woman here for six years we are now
looking to get married and buy a home
and I just had a few questions on what
to watch out for what to look for as far
as loans and everything goes Love's
exciting wow you are this is incredible
what's your income
uh so um they're actually starting me
out here at 65 000 a year great good for
you what's her income uh we have been
interesting for the down payment sets
and I think we've been able to put away
roughly 20 000 together since high
school so cool when when do you plan on
putting a ring on it uh here you know in
the next couple of months we're kind of
looking you know probably late March
early April
okay well for sure I want you guys
married before you purchase this home
together and so absolutely I'm not
trying to speed up the you get married
when you need to get married but do not
buy a home together before you're
married that is a recipe for disaster
absolutely I'd even suggest George
waiting a year yeah I mean could you
guys rent for a year continue to save up
a down payment which gives you more
options when it comes to housing
okay there's just so much going on that
first year of marriage Cooper it's your
whole life has changed everything you
know is different and so throwing a home
purchase on top of that is a lot and so
I think just you're trying to figure out
which way the dishes go in the
dishwasher okay that's a whole year
right there it is a whole year because
she's got a method
so I love the goal being a homeowner
you're 19. dude you're gonna be so far
ahead of the game if you are completely
debt free with a pile of money in the
bank and your down payment is that your
situation that is currently my situation
so neither of you have debt you both
have savings
yeah we both have savings with work and
do that between both of us that's great
and and that one year gives you time to
save up more of a down payment yes and
so the parameters to help you out with
this we've got a great calculator on our
website at ramseysolutions.com to
calculate your mortgage but we want you
to do a 15-year fixed where the payment
is no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay and uh with your situation
it'd be so cool to put down 20 or more
yeah to avoid that PMI private mortgage
insurance where you're just handing the
lender more money for fund to protect
them that's a bad plan yes sir I would
aim for 20 or more do the 15-year fix
jump on the calculator and then it'll
tell you hey you really should afford
you could afford a 200 000 home and you
might need to go all right we're gonna
get a condo or a town home if we want a
home in the next year or you say we're
going to wait and save up more and
that'll give us more options so you guys
are putting yourself in an amazing Place
financially to do this and also remember
your cash flowing the ring your cash
flowing the wedding there's a lot of
upcoming expenses you got to worry about
too which is why it's also great to rent
for a while get your bearings under you
before you jump into this hang on the
line Austin is going to gift you guys
one year of Financial Peace University
as kind of a
pre-pre-marital counseling so that's
exciting man congrats on the impending
engagement and marriage you're crushing
it at 19 years old this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour this is the Ramsey Show
you know we love generosity around here
and we also love things that are free
and a free way to be generous is to tell
someone about this show to share it to
leave us a review wherever you're
listening wherever you're watching to
subscribe that is some great free
generosity it costs you nothing so if
you enjoy this show we want to impact
the most amount of people this year and
especially get into new people's hands
and ears oh yeah and so please please if
you enjoy the show do all of those
things
cost you nothing it costs you nothing it
costs you isn't I feel like that's a
quote right there it costs you nothing
to mind your business I feel like I've
heard that one to my zero dollars I like
that it's a little snippy I thought
you'd use that on your kids or something
I might tonight put them in their place
I might tonight because my son let me
know how it goes
I can't use it on my dogs they don't
care they don't care I like that it
costs you nothing to mind your business
it's free it's free oh give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll talk about your life and your
money Kevin has decided to do that over
in Miami Florida Kevin welcome to the
show
hello Georgia and Jen thank you so much
for taking my call sure we're doing good
how can we help today
yeah so I have a question regarding uh a
vehicle that my fiance is financing
we're trying to sell it because uh she
can't well we can't really or she can't
really afford the payments so we we kind
of want to figure if we should sell the
car or or keep and try to pay off as
quickly as possible with some savings
that I have right before the wedding how
much are the payments
so yeah so the payment is 425 and how
much is the car worth
uh the car loan is 25
000 and we looked at um we looked around
to see how much they would give us on
um ebk and it's about 20K okay is that
private party value
or is that like trade-in dealership
private it's about 20 uh like 21 and
then dealers about 1920. okay how much
money does she have in savings if any
uh I think the only saving she has is
really the savings that we've been
putting well her savings towards the
wedding okay which is how much yeah
uh I believe she has maybe I believe
it's about 2 500. okay and then we're
been cash flowing uh the wedding so the
only money that she has is the 2500 and
do you happen to know what her income is
yeah so her income is about 2 000 a
month okay so yeah this car is too
expensive for her I just want to
reiterate that you know right now until
you're married you are keeping these
finances separate and if I were her I
would sell this car I'd sell it and I
would use the proceeds to cash flow
something that's less expensive that I
would pay cash for and you know you
never know if she doesn't have any other
debt you could throw some of this into
that wedding fund does she have any
other debt
uh no it's just basically the vehicle
okay so she's under water on this car
you're saying where it's it's only worth
20. she owes 25. so we need to come up
with five thousand dollars fast and so
she has a little bit of that in savings
how quickly could she save up another
2500
uh to be honest I I don't think that
quickly because she's very her margins
aren't great especially yes we're saving
for the wedding is she working full-time
right now uh yeah she's working
full-time or a full-time student as well
as me okay
um I'm wondering if there's a better job
out there that can get her more than two
grand a month if she's working full time
I'm wondering the same thing and have
you actually set the date for the
wedding or is it still yet to be
determined
no yeah we have the wedding
um late April okay so the date is set so
you're kind of under the gun here are
you guys having to pay for this all
yourselves or is family involved
uh our parents helped us
um some with the venue but we we've been
paying everything off ourselves okay and
are they in a financial position to help
anymore with the wedding if you went to
them and said Hey listen we can't cover
this we've got a situation with with her
car and so her wedding savings has to go
towards solving this problem would they
be willing to pitch in more or could you
scale down the wedding
um I don't think they'll be they're
financially able to help as much as they
they would like or as much as they have
before
Kevin
what's your situation financially what
are you bringing home
I'm bringing home about 2 200 a month
and are you a student as well
yeah yeah full-time influence student
okay and do you have any debt
uh no
cool so again don't put a dime towards
her debt until you guys are already
married
yeah and the other thing she can look
into is a personal loan from like a
credit union locally to cover the
difference of the amount you're upside
down on
and so she can put 1500 towards it that
means she needs another 3 500 and a
personal loan to get out from under this
and it's the only time we would tell you
to go into debt which is really just
reducing your debt load currently that's
right from 25 000 in debt to thirty five
hundred that's a much more manageable
number for her with her income would you
agree
yeah no definitely okay and yeah I would
just look into that as your as an option
if because her income's not there to
save up this money anytime soon and
she'll just need a beater car to get
around for now maybe she can borrow one
from family whatever she's got to do uh
to get to that wedding to where you guys
can combine finances hopefully you've
graduated you can increase that income
exponentially putting you guys in a much
better place financially it's good
advice George that's a that's a tough
situation and y'all car payments man it
is just killing America and interest
rates have skyrocketed unbelievable it's
a terrible time to buy a car with a loan
it is it always was but it's an
especially bad time right now yeah and
that was that that loan was eating up a
lot of her money she was only bringing
in 2 000 a month so yikes all right
Cody's up next and Tyler Texas Cody
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thank you for having me absolutely
what's going on
well uh I've worked in the oil field for
13 years and about six months ago
uh eight months ago on my way to work I
got rear ended by a drunk driver oh
shoot
I mean there's an upside to it because I
got a good settlement from it are you
all right
yeah now I am yeah I am now any residual
effects are you still going to the
doctor are you healed up
for the most part I'd say my brain's 80
now oh man that's scary I'm sorry
oh thank you three days after the record
I can't get to my favorite Mexican
restaurant but I'm doing better now
that's a problem if that hey if that's
one of your top concerns you you're
doing all right by the grace of God sure
all right so what's your question is
it is uh I got uh after everything was
paid the lawyer all that I got a 500 000
settlement wow cash in my bank account
and uh
I'm trying to figure out if I should
invest it or start a Vehicles do you
have any debt
no no debt how much do you have already
in savings
um well since the wreck I wasn't able to
work for a while so it dwindled down but
all together now it's about 5 40. cool
cool and do you have a retirement
account through your employer
uh no I I was contract okay and then are
you a homeowner
no are you wanting to this because I
would rather you put that money into a
home than put it into a fun business
venture right absolutely
and not that he has to put all not that
you have to put all of it into a home
but
you have the ability to set yourself
throw that route should I wait
I mean with this kind of money I would
pause anyways and I'd get a solid team
around you number one you need a real
estate expert a tax Pro would be great
an investing Pro you can connect with
all those at ramseysolutions.com but I
want you to walk with a lot of patience
with this kind of money because you've
never handled this kind of money I
assume
no sir and so it's easy it's it's like
you just won the lottery and what we
find with lottery winners is they lose
all of that money and I lose I mean they
spent it
yeah they go broke instantly correct it
was it was about two months that I've
gotten paid and I've kind of just been
hiding almost going uh crazy because I
don't know exactly what to do and I
don't want to make those mistakes when
do you think you'll be able to go back
to work
or is that um I I don't think I could
work on a drilling rig anymore I think
those days are behind those are over so
well we're going to send you Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
to help you on the career side and on
the financial side I'm going to walk
real slow and if you want to get a place
with cash that's reasonable do that the
rest you can just park in a high yield
savings account for now and don't mess
with it that's what I would personally
do to make sure this wealth works for
you down the line wow that's quite the
situation thanks for the call that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined this hour by Jade
warshaw one of our newest Ramsay
personalities and we're having a good
time here and we're excited to take your
calls about life and money and here's
the number triple eight eight two five
five two two five Stephen kicks off this
hour in Charlotte North Carolina Stephen
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how are you doing thank you for
having me absolutely how can we help
um yes so I am currently a full-time
student
um also have a full-time job just
finishing up my last year in school what
do I have around 20 000 in student loans
and 10 000 in car uh a car loan that I
have
um I was just trying to get more advice
on how to kind of handle all of that
while finishing school should I wait
till after should I start tackling this
debt now my income's pretty good
although I think after I graduate it
will be much more so I would just
calling to get some advice what's the
income now
um around 55. and that's pretty good
it's impressive man full-time student
yeah how much time did you say you have
until you graduate
uh this is my last year okay
now go ahead George looking at your
income looking at the payments are you
able to cash flow the remainder of
school
um so I did just take out recently a
loan in order to uh finish up my summer
classes and everything that's kind of
where I have to is that part of the 20
that you mentioned
correct okay that's total okay so the
damn the damage is done there and so if
school is completely covered we could go
ahead and start to pay this off since
you are working full-time and there's no
danger of going into more debt
I would especially depending on the type
of loan you have student loan
and uh recently I just got a raise so
after taking out that loan um I thought
it would be best to kind of put that
loan back
um while there's no interest on it and
just kind of pay out of pocket since I
have the remaining money to do so that's
great you say put the loan back what do
you mean by that
um so after they refunded me out for
what I was going to pay out of pocket
for uh summer part of that loan I could
just kind of pay it back to the lender
and then pay my cash uh for my whatever
I need to pay in summer cool
so if you're if you're following the
Ramsey plan your first A1 would be a
thousand dollar emergency fund do you
have that already
uh yes okay how much money do you have
beyond that
um I have around nine thousand ten
thousand dollars saved oh wow that's
great so we're about ready to Let's get
this car in this car alone
right right that's great yeah you can do
that you could do that tomorrow
okay
it's not a joke yeah
okay take that 9k put it towards the car
you'll have 1K left and then you've got
this great income where you can start
cash flowing your debt snowball
so once you have eleven thousand dollars
to your name you can clean clean up that
car loan and still have that thousand
dollar emergency fund now we're ready to
tackle the student loan and if you can
pay that off before you graduate that
would be amazing are you able to pay off
the loan before graduation
um I think it would be uh just based off
how the Iran and stuff has gone up in
this area it would be kind of difficult
but
um I think I could it's just a cool
stretch goal I'm doing now you seem like
a driven guy who's ready to to clean
this up and so I just love the idea of
you graduating completely debt free with
no payments you'd be such a unicorn and
then you'd be able to save up that three
to six months in no time
right I know it's not the most extreme
situation but just watching all the
recent videos I'm like I should probably
figure out the best way to handle this
now so that's oh yeah
that's great Steven well you know when
it comes to extreme and I've I've been
there it can feel extreme I mean there's
people who have seven thousand dollars
in debt and it feels like they can't
breathe and so don't don't minimize your
situation man you becoming debt free at
your age is incredible it is it is life
goals I wish I had been let that way at
19 and 20 and 21. these young cats man
there's they're smarter than that early
they are so much smarter than I was back
in the day so all right Cassandra is up
next in St Louis Cassandra welcome to
the show
we sound great
okay hi
my I'm I'm just feeling kind of lost in
my debt we're trying to pay off all of
um my student loans and medical bills
um while also trying to get a house and
so now I'm feeling overwhelmed with it
all because I got in a car crash this
morning
are you all right
yeah I'm okay my car's not but
well let's let's see if we can ease some
of this stress for you today I'm glad
that you're feeling I'm glad that the
car crash wasn't more than what it was
especially with the call we had earlier
my son wasn't in the car so yes a
blessing me too me too so what's your
income
um I'm currently making um
4 000 a month take home cool and so is
my husband
so 8K total so we're talking about 100K
take-home pay
roughly yeah okay how much student loan
debt do you have
um I have a 37 000 right now I'm still
in school I'm expecting it to be
um 42 when I graduate but I'm
hoping that we can pay it off before I
graduate well let's let's try to let's
try to set this up to where you're not
taking out any more student loans so
that's what we're going to try to walk
you through here because you've got debt
we don't want to create any more debt so
you got the 37k and student loans and
you mentioned medical debt can you tell
us about that
how much that is yes I it's um it's
roughly 22
000 right now and is there any other
debt on the table between you and your
husband
no um he has 4 000 in medical debt um
but we already paid off our credit card
okay so no credit cards so it's just a
37 22 and the 4K correct
yeah okay all right so you guys are
making a great income AK a month 100K
take home you're in 63 of debt do you
have anything in savings
um we currently have 13
000 in savings
um because we're trying to buy a home
we're living with the in-laws and that's
not going over too well anymore so okay
so what I think we need to do is focus
on one thing at a time at this point
we're not in a really great position to
start buying a home you've got this debt
around your neck you're trying to finish
school if I'm you I'm going to take a
look at this 13k that you have in
savings and I'm just going to walk it
through the baby steps so the way that
we teach is baby step one is getting a
thousand dollars saved that's thing one
so out of that 13k in savings I'm gonna
put 1K aside and then that's going to
leave me with 12K to start putting
towards debt
does that sound right
yeah and then so you can go ahead and
knock out your husband's 4K bill with
that and then after that you've got a
little bit left to throw onto that
medical debt and then from then on I'm
just going to walk out the baby step two
in order I'm going to keep working that
debt snowball like George said you've
got a great income start paying down
that debt with the Vengeance if you can
pick up extra income that's great and
then once that debt is knocked out we
can go to our three to six months of
expenses start building back up that
savings and I want to make this clear
don't start saving that for that house
until you get that debt cleared up and
until you get to baby step 3B and once
you guys are out of debt maybe you move
out and you rent it for a while but home
ownership is a more distant dream and I
want you to do it when the timing is
right and so you'll get there in no time
if you do this stuff in order with
focused intensity and cash flow that's
cool absolutely this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
State and I want you to have a house but
I don't want a house to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell host of the fine print
entree leadership and co-host of smart
money happy hour joined by Jay warshaw
and Jade we are both pretty frugal
people I would like to say this is true
George and a lot of people are
struggling right now with inflation in
the economy and there's too much month
at the end of their money so I thought
it would be fun if we gave our listeners
our viewers some inflation hacks per se
I love it and when I say tax they all
take work and so there's no true like
life hack this is here's some sacrifices
you can make to find some margin and
create some margin in your budget every
single month so that you can accomplish
your money goals most of them are pretty
simple changes though if we really look
at this list George let's get into it
yeah so let's start with groceries
because that seems to be on everyone's
mind right now none of these will blow
your mind but knowing when to buy in
bulk so you can ask yourself a few
questions can I eat it before it goes
bad because if you buy in bulk and it
all goes bad you wasted a whole bunch of
money is the price per ounce cheaper
most people are not doing the math a lot
of times it's actually on the label it
will show you the per ounce price and so
just because you got it at the Wholesale
Club doesn't always mean it's cheaper
than at their local groceries that's
true I made that mistake with jelly and
here's a big question asked do I have
room to store all of this muclix so much
music oh don't do it so storage can be
it can be a problem if you don't have a
lot of space and then obviously will I
actually use this so there's some of
course choosing generic brands that's a
tough one for a lot of people who are
married to their brand name they're made
in the same Factory people it's just
marketing it's literally just a
different label on it let your tell your
brain that next time you go to the store
because it's true yeah the acid
Dominican versus the Tylenol is the same
thing made on the same line yep and you
know I love this one George eat less
meat that's a big one for you that's
coming from me y'all know I'm the
resident you're a vegetarian me eating
Americans when you say stuff like that
it's not a look I'm not telling them to
go hungry I'm telling them to eat a
different form of protein and a lot of
times you're getting the same amount of
protein per ounce I just feel used to it
tofu infringes on my rights as an
American George you come to the house
tonight I will prepare you the best tofu
you've ever had in your life and you
will Rave and you will go on the streets
and rip your shirt off until these
people how great that's not this tofu
America needs right now unbelievable
another thing you can do switch up the
grocery store a lot of you you're stuck
I go to this grocery store but I'm
telling you Christina Ellis is doing her
no spend challenge she's been shopping
at Aldi and I'm just shocked at how how
much she can stretch those dogs she's
spending under a hundred dollars a week
for a family of four family four don't
don't tell me it can't be done it can be
done shopping online can be helpful if
you're one of those compulsive going by
the snack aisle type Shoppers so
ordering in the app for pickup and maybe
having an accountability partner to look
over what you are ordering be careful
though because sometimes in those apps
they do add premiums I know the Publix
apps they the Publix app trips just I'm
letting you know I would much rather do
that with like some of the other apps
that don't add as much of a premium
that's good and of course meal plan Jade
you're amazing at this I know it's work
people are like meal plan it's like
CrossFit I'm not there's too much work
it's work on the front end what you need
to do is get a list of me like start
start out by writing out all the meals
you love all your family favorites then
you can come on websites or or you know
social medias like mine and get you know
some other ideas and then after that
it's just about plug and play the
hardest part is writing out and really
getting that kind of list of all the
things that you like to eat separating
it out but we've got you covered well
now you can just Google and YouTube all
this stuff you can't invent it from
scratch no you don't but you know people
eat the same thing over and over they
get bored and uh we don't need to talk
about eating out because the best hack
for inflation is just to not eat out if
you don't have to and if you if you are
like I don't have enough money at the
end of the month one of the easiest ways
to make money back into your life is by
not eating out it is astronomically
expensive these days and okay that's a
good point George but even for folks
let's say you're in baby step three and
you're doing you know you're past that
baby step two phase but you're still
like man this inflation and you're going
to restaurants every now and then can
you can you pick it up instead of dining
in yes you can avoid the tip and here's
my favorite tip for folks who are still
going to restaurants but trying to save
leave your kids at home that's big don't
bring those but then you gotta hire a
babysitter you gotta offset the cost now
George I would rather pay for child care
than to pay 14 for whatever their food
was and it ends up on the floor oh and
I'm talking about times two because I
got two kids warshaw kids she's coming
for you all right let's move on to
housing and utility saving on your
electric bill there's a lot of things
you can do here number one replace those
air filters they're probably crispy and
nasty and it's time anyways that's right
your air filter your your HVAC is having
to work so hard it's working overtime
because of those nasty filters only run
appliances when they're full that means
being a little more strategic a little
more patient turn off the dang lights
when you're not using them yeah if my
dad is listening he's like yes I want to
know how much does it really saved
because I grew up on that today's job it
adds up cut that light off uh and
washing your clothes in cold water I was
just watching someone who's an appliance
Pro and they were like washing cold
water with today's detergents it's going
to clean it just as well as your hot
water yes it does that's a great one
save money there
um water bills take quicker showers
notice I didn't say fewer I said quicker
some of y'all y'all need to you're
hanging out like it's a hot tub in there
get get what you need to get done and
get out why are you coming at me this
hour why are you coming at me well this
is I think this is a woman problem now
some guys probably take super long
showers
the long hot shower until the skin comes
off oh I'm just burning myself in there
uh don't run the dishwasher or laundry
until the machine is full that's another
good one turn off your TAP when you
brush your teeth I'm guilty of that one
when you're shaving washing your hair
turn off the tap don't just let it run
for fun that is very good we live in a
society people act like it and then you
can install a low flow shower head so
now people get upset about this one this
is taking it too far well some of those
shower heads I mean this just the the
pressure coming out of those things will
take your skin off so yeah I'm just
saying all that helps rent this is a
tough one right people are going well my
rent's so expensive if you're single it
may be time to get a roommate and cut it
out yeah if you're married some married
couples are like we got an extra room
we're going to use this to make money we
did it when we were in baby step two our
rent was 1200 a month and we as married
people got roommates who were other
married people and we did it for a year
and saved 600 bucks a month that's a
life hack right there and then you can
also look into a lease that's longer
than a year if you know you're going to
be somewhere for a while you can sign up
for a longer lease which can lower your
rent which is great and here's a life
hack move out and find somewhere cheaper
to live it exists and you might not want
to do it but that's that's one way to
lower your cost there transportation is
another one that has gotten real
expensive and so things like combining
your errands there are gas reward
programs out there that are free that
can save you a few cents on the dollar
you probably have all this all the crap
in your car that maybe weighing down
your car that's true and that can help
with your fuel economy and cruise
control aggressively speeding breaking
on the highway all that that can lower
your gas mileage by from 50 cents to two
dollars a gallon two dollars that's true
just I I remember my dad used to tell me
take the highway because it's less stop
and go and you'll save on gas dads way
to go Dad way to go there they were the
first Frugal folks out there I love it
he was the one that said cut the light
off and now let's end with some
lifestyle savings hacks and the biggest
one is subscriptions
we live in the subscription economy and
they all add up and everyone wants to
nickel and dime you for their thing
Prime has gotten I love me some prime
but they've gotten out of control with
this price so if you let's just say you
cut you know Netflix is now 16 bucks a
month Spotify is 10 bucks a month 12
bucks a month Hulu without the ads of 13
bucks a month that's 50 bucks a month
just on TV shows and music and I can't
keep up with the amount of content on
there now if you have enough can can I
just say this I'm about to to harp on so
and I'm talking to myself too if you
have all these subscriptions and you're
using all you're watching that much TV
we need to find something else to do
with our time and I'm saying we an hour
because I'm in it too well what's
amazing is you cut all the subscriptions
because you got a part-time job now
because you're trying to get out of debt
yeah you don't miss it no too busy
you're too busy working and that's 600
bucks a year that you can throw at debt
you can afford your groceries all that
kind of stuff and extra time you'll have
when you're not you're watching I don't
know what the cool shows are Emily in
Paris I don't know what's cool these
days it sounds like you watch Emily in
Paris George
don't buy clothing unless it's an actual
need so many clothes in America today
your closet is just full of crap that
you once thought was going to be cute
yeah and now it's still got tags on and
there's really cool ways that you can do
those clothing exchanges too like if you
have something and you paid a little bit
of money for it you can go on one of
those exchanges sell it and then maybe
take the money and either put it towards
debt or buy something else so it's more
of an exchange yes and lastly make
coffee at home I know it's one of those
tried and true wow what's the five bucks
oh it it's safe and it tastes better
George because it you get it right every
time that's right and you can make your
own little frothy lattes at home it's 14
cheaper than Starbucks and no more gas
station runs that is keeping y'all broke
every day do my little snack in my
little drink that's how they're making
their money and it's putting the pounds
on too
don't don't sleep on it good hacks
thanks Jade
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show
I know most of you are glad to be a rid
of 2022 because it was hard to keep gas
in the car food in the fridge and money
is still tight a few days later here in
2023 and you might be wondering if this
year is going to be any different if
you're going to be able to make any
progress if you're going to be able to
pay the bills and build wealth and you
don't have to live through another year
of stress and worry we are doing a free
live stream event this Thursday called
Building Wealth in 2023 because we want
to show you that it is still possible to
make progress on those goals to build
wealth to have peace with your money
even in this crazy economy
during this event you're going to hear
from Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz myself and
we're going to be joined by John deloney
and Ken Coleman to have some fun talking
about how to set goals how to create
margins so that you can build wealth
this year and uh here's the good news
it's completely free so it's a great
event to send to your friends send to
the folks you wish were on the Ramsay
plan and go hey could you spare an hour
of your time to tune into this free live
stream wherever you are in the world
um go to ramseysolutions.com wealth to
sign up for the free live stream that is
ramseysolutions.com
wealth Jade you'll be watching I hope I
will definitely be watching I love those
live streams and they always come at the
right time
just when you need it they've helped Sam
and I in many a a hard time many many a
dark dark hour well I'm gonna tease a
little bit of what's what's going to be
in this event Dave is going to kick it
off with a state of the union talking
about all the things all the things
we're feeling all the different aspects
of the economy from the inflation the
recession the stock market roller
coaster the job market Consumer Debt
anxiety and really Center it and bring
us home with some hope and then I'll get
out there and hopefully have a good time
showing people how to create margin in
their finances regardless of where
they're at and a lot of that is we got
to get on a debt we got to get on a
budget we got to find where all the
money leaks are happening yes in our
life and take control of that income our
greatest wealth building tool I love it
and then finally Rachel Cruz she's she's
going to be kind of closing out to the
keynote section talking about how to
ride this roller coaster and how to
addressing all the fears that we have
when it comes to investing because so
many people don't do it because there's
legitimate fear and they're going I
don't want to lose money I'm risk averse
yeah I'm conservative I don't want and
because of that they retire with nothing
oh that's no way to be we can't let our
fear guide absolutely and so beyond that
we're going to have a fun round table
with Ken Coleman and Dr Dr John deloney
joining that's a good time a lot of
surprises you don't want to miss it I
love it January 12th 7 P.M Central Time
8 PM eastern time go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth facts over fears
Max is up next in Phoenix Arizona Max
welcome to the Ramsey show my friend how
you doing
good how about yourself doing great
what's your question today
all right so
so it's a little bit more of a broad one
I am just for context 19 years old
um I do work full-time been working
full-time for the last year and a half I
make about 200 000 a year what do you do
yeah
I uh sell cars excellent that's a lot of
cars
yeah how did you do this at 19.
uh it really was just being relentless
um there are a couple programs in my
area I started going investing really
myself uh going to like training
seminars stuff like that and really I
mean I've worked 12 hours a day then
study four hours a day wow that's
amazing basic selling and um
first year I really struggled and you
know I mean struggles I made 100 Grand
my first year but um quite the struggle
there for for an 18 year old yeah I know
right wow so that's really good yeah but
now the market shifted and
um again I was just ready for it and um
now I'm just looking on how I can invest
properly I don't have a lot of depth
um I do have a leased car I've spoken
like a true car salesman right how much
yeah other than the car and I want to
know how much the the car debt is do you
have any other debt
no I have no other Dad I just have rent
okay so just the car lease
correct okay you know this better than
anyone what is the early buyout amount
on that car
30 grand okay
well how much money do you have in the
bank
um well so it'd be just to explain it
better the residual value and it's 30
grand that's the buyout plus what I
currently make payments on which is 20
grand so be a total of 50. oh oh my Lord
that's the full early buy it amount if
you wanted to own this car free and
clear
yes it's a 65 000 car what kind of car
is this
it is a Infiniti Q60 red sport wow sick
Whip and if you oh my goodness well the
good news is as a part of your world and
your income right now it's actually
reasonable if you can continue to make
two hundred thousand dollars
now if you make a hundred thousand next
year we got a problem that's right right
yes I can terminate the lease early for
five thousand dollars and turn it in
tomorrow and forget about it as a five
thousand dollar stupid tax and call it a
day
correct all right you have the money to
pay it off what's the big question
that's on your mind that we can help
with today
really it's just a I'm trying to start
saving my money spending my money a
little more wisely
um I have about a hundred grand in the
bank right now what amazing yeah
and I'm trying to learn how to invest
that
it just really get started and I have
deep outside of the car I'm very frugal
saver I know where my money goes but I'm
really I just found days about months
ago so I just started getting into it
I'm probably going to go through uh
Financial Peace here shortly if I'm
really just trying to dial in on this
and figure out how do I invest that
money
so as a car salesman you are you your
own man or are you on
do they offer any benefits towards you
is what I'm asking to to figure out what
your retirement situation looks like
401K they do offer a 401k is there a
match yes
uh 50 sweet is it up to a certain amount
yeah it's up to I believe 20 of your
take home cool wonderful well that's a
great place to start yeah
as far as have you been doing that
yeah I haven't been doing the full 20
I've been doing about 10 which it is
commission it fluctuates a little bit
um just taking 10 of it a month is
really about a grand two grand a month
give or take huh so we could you could
really walk up the baby steps with this
you know you could make sure that out of
that 100K you're keeping three to six
months of expenses out in your case I'd
go ahead and keep six months out just
because your profession is a little bit
more volatile and there's only one of
you it's only one income so I'd keep six
months of that I would continue to do
the 15 investing and you know do you
have any goals you're 19 are you
thinking about I mean
housing wise
yeah I've been I've been looking at it I
mean I just moved to Phoenix about six
months ago
um so I I'm still learning the area very
smart
um moved from Nashville Tennessee
actually right yes very smart keep doing
that keep learning the area give
yourself about a year over there and I
think that you can kind of keep some of
this money stashed away maybe in a good
money market account where it's getting
some interest and when you're ready you
know you're gonna have a nice Hefty down
payment when the time comes yeah I mean
with your income you truly could pay
cash for something if you want to go
real intense but as long as you've got
20 or more down you know with your
situation you could put 10 but you make
so much there's no ways to go if you
couldn't have plenty one for the gold
get a 15-year fixed rate mortgage I know
that's controversial in today's society
but man when you get a 15-year where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay you have money left
over which means you can live your life
you can pay it off early which means in
your 20s you could have a paid for house
think about that that's right no
payments in the world a giant pile of
money in the bank and the rest of your
life ahead of you to continue investing
you could buy more property with cash
you can just the world is your oyster at
that point and Max no more leases no all
right that was it we learned the lesson
the snake bit us we're not leasing
because I want all the other car
salesmen to look at you at 19 making
this kind of money with no car lease and
they're going I don't understand Max
leasing is great we this is what we do
for a living you go nah dude I found
Dave Ramsey I'm trying to live a
debt-free life and they're gonna look at
you going will you show me how you oh
you're in oh wow you're investing that
much you're working for a house okay I'm
listening to Max's playing now all right
I love it go dude that's that's
inspiring right there's young people
killing it step it up old people Max has
got you beat are you talking to me
George no I didn't look at you when I
said it I was I was not making eye
contact this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show our scripture of
the day comes from Proverbs 15 23. a
person finds joy in giving an apt reply
and how good is a timely word
Ralph Waldo Emerson said our chief want
is someone who will inspire us to be
what we know we could be
that's a good coach right there love it
all right let's go to Jake in Billings
Montana Jake welcome to the Ramsay show
yeah hey uh George and Jade uh thanks
for taking my call you're welcome a
first time caller so bear with me I'm a
little nervous but um oh it's all right
we'll get through it yeah so
um uh long story short we found out last
week that my dad's got uh terminal
cancer and probably got weeks maybe
months and um
I trust you guys opinion on things and I
just wanted to see uh if there's
anything that
you know we haven't thought of that
maybe you guys would recommend we
check into or do before all that takes
place Jake I'm so so sorry
that's tough what kind of cancer is it
uh lung cancer if it's spread to
everything else ah I'm so sorry well
we're happy to to give you some some
good next steps and kind of a checklist
of things to go through
um is there other family in the picture
there's her mom yeah yep yep um yep mom
mom and dad are still married
um and then my brother and I okay
well does he have a will in place or an
estate plan
they do have a will I'm sure it's a
simple will but yeah they had it grown
up a couple of years ago now
um I would triple check that and maybe
go over it with them and have him make
sure all the you know the eyes are
dotted the t's are crossed there yeah do
you know do they have any debt
no they do not yeah as well oh wonderful
what a blessing that is so the other
pieces of information that would be
really helpful is where all the
information insurance information any
important information logins make sure
that's all written down somewhere that
you'll have access to
okay yeah
and that's that's the not fun part about
that there's just so many places to
start writing that stuff down account
numbers contact information all of that
okay okay
and is he still in a spot where he's
able to to interact with you guys
yes yep yep he is okay it may be
uh special for him to make videos for
each person in the family saying
everything that he wants to say that
that's such a gift to have that
has he considered doing that
no it's not something we talked about
yet
I think that'd be a wonderful gift yeah
yeah it's not an easy thing to do but
man you will you will treasure that for
the rest of your life yeah
yeah I think we would yeah it yeah it
makes you really reevaluate your time
with somebody for sure and so yeah we're
just trying to wrap our heads around
that but is there any kind of a bucket
list things that he's mentioned
that he wants to do that he's able to do
[Music]
Point Mobility is a major issue but his
mind is still good yeah what's your
dad's name
all right Nick man it sounds like Nick
was a great dad he's really set you guys
up no debt yeah the will in place I mean
that is just such a it's such a blessing
that's such a legacy that's right George
yeah and uh as far as expenses funeral
expenses is all of that going to be
covered
well so yeah that's that's
kind of you know that started all this
discussion um the funeral he wants it
simple but like you know we've never had
to plan anything like that so I'm not
sure
what if if there's things that you know
we're simply not aware of um we did get
um oh the the funeral home or I guess
well it's the funeral plot Place
involved and so we're asking those
questions with them but uh kind of
looking at where to where to go from
there too yeah and and just make sure in
the will all of all of his wishes are in
there
yeah that's why it's a good idea to go
over it ahead of time I mean it I know
it would be difficult but have everybody
in the room everybody that it involves
go through that make sure like like
George said all the eyes are dotted T's
are crossed and everybody's
understanding what the what the next
step's gonna be
yeah yeah that's a great idea I think
we'll do that
um we'll go pull that out we also have
an estate planning checklist that will
make sure you get the link to when you
get off the phone oh you do yeah and
that would be great just to be able to
go through that
um there's several steps that you can
just make sure this is all taken care of
and it's going to give you peace through
all this as well
okay cool yeah that'll be super helpful
is there an executor of the will
currently
uh yes I I guess would that default to
my mom
um
it sounds like it would I would just
double check the language in there
because that whatever that will says is
what's going to happen
okay and uh you may have to go through
probate to finalize all the assets and
all of that
um so I would also get in touch with an
estate attorney and figure out all that
stuff ahead of time because the last
thing you want is oh I didn't understand
or I didn't know and I didn't know the
assets move this way and here's what we
have to go through and this could take
months and so I just want you to make
sure you you know exactly what's coming
because I want you to have space to
grieve instead of have to deal with all
the details and how 62.
2 okay and she's in good health
yeah
yeah she sure is she sure is yeah but
yeah it's that weird stuff like I don't
know what'll happen with you know like
his Ira I know he's got to roll over Ira
or Social Security and I I don't know
how that all plays out but yeah you want
to make sure she's set up with you know
whatever whoever you were using or your
dad was using or that they were using
making sure that she was fully a part of
that and understands all the Investments
understands what the game plan is there
I would go through every single account
and for bank accounts for example make
sure that she's joint on that bank
account so everything would just flow to
her making sure on the IRA that you have
the beneficiary set up and it's who you
want it to be and so those are some
pieces of the puzzle that you could
knock out quickly to give you some peace
of mind when it comes to the financial
side
yeah but I assume she's going to
continue living in their paid for home
yeah yeah she perhaps
you know it's from acreage it would be a
lot for her to maintain but we could
rent it if we had to my wife and I
um have had rentals and still do so like
we could figure that out and
um is this kind of family land that
you'd want to keep generationally or is
this something where she might be
willing to sell it downsize later on
um we would certainly prefer to keep it
like it's an awesome Place uh but that's
it's up to her at the end of the day
it's that's entirely her decision yeah
well part of this is just supporting mom
and obviously the rest of the family
yeah through all of this and man you
this whole family just sounds incredible
I'm like this is the kind of family I
want to be absolutely what kind of dad I
would want to be so and they're
wonderful to have a son like you
stepping in and make sure making sure
everything is is in place and that this
is as smooth of a journey as possible so
thank you for that how old are you doing
my brother and I are both oh yeah 35. I
can't imagine it's an Apparent at that
age man I'm so sorry
yeah it came as a heck of a surprise
it's a real punch in the gut for
everybody but have they been following
the Ramsay plan like did they get you
guys turned on to all this
um no they've always just been very
frugal just common sense like I can't
say that I'm a Ramsay follower but I I
definitely practice the same things that
you guys preach I guess so like my wife
and I are debt free as well and stuff so
like it's all good
um financially financially we're all
good I just don't know what
is coming you know this is a new one
yeah yeah well with all the unknowns
there there's a lot of things that are
in your control right now to to knock
out and give the family some space to
grieve and I'll send you a copy of John
deloney's book own your past change your
future there's a lot of principles in
there that I think will help you and the
family grieve through this process all
of this in a healthy way and we're also
going to make sure you get that estate
planning checklist which is free online
if you just Google Ramsay estate
planning checklist but we'll get you the
specific link Austin will uh he'll
figure that one out for us
but Jade what a lesson in Legacy oh my
goodness saying I love you to your
family in such a tactical way oh he has
proven that that is the
taking care of your money well is one of
the greatest ways that you can love your
family well because this could have been
filled with chaos I would have been
filled with to be a nightmare and
instead it was just like oh yeah he did
that we've got the will in place so if
you're listening America get a will done
today today two day go to our website
we've got a link over there to our
friends at Mama Bear legal forums you
can do this online and it doesn't take
long and it's just one thing to check
off you're not gonna die any sooner if
you get a will in place by the way right
but man what a legacy Jake we are
thinking of you and your family today
that's right during this really really
difficult time appreciate you trusting
us with this call that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books my thanks
to Jade warshaw all the folks in the
booth and new America until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]